you
hi everyone is cherry I'm I just got
paired up on chest comm playing a 15-2
game
let's try I'd have three as a start I
don't like the looks of this early part
of the game here this little bar for the
connection doesn't appear to be too
exciting here hopefully we could get the
full game in otherwise you won't be
watching this video okay so let's go at
c4 see what black does it's a very
flexible start get that night behind
them
maybe I'll go with the g3 maybe d4 let's
see what black does next okay hmm let's
get my knight here still leaping some
options open I'm not sure if I'm gonna
feel kind of the bishop or go elsewhere
go with me for preparing to build a pawn
center of three and this particular move
order I wanted to also stay clear of the
Grune felled so me for first and then d4
I'm castles Bishop e2 castles let's see
what black does quite often why could
end up with the space advantage with
this group of puns challenged with c5
there's d5 and similarly with the e5 you
could be considering d5 but on e5 I
might want to go for a variation that's
a bit more tame ok black doesn't appear
to be going in that direction on e5 I
was going to consider capturing so
what's the intention behind this main
one I believe is to get a 5 in and
vacate this c5 square for the knight
although I think there is also c5 so
these are the two paunch strikes
something has to come so
thing has to disrupt this pawn Center so
we'll see how this plays out is there
reason not to castle right now what are
my other candidate moves I think I want
to maintain maintain some flexibility
uh-huh so let's let's make the move I
know I'm going to have to make let's do
that right away and let's see what black
comes up with c5 okay I'm going to grab
some space
let's get d5 in so this knight Knight a
six to c7 blacks plan one of the plans
at least pawn brake wise will be to get
in b-59 c7 rook b8 and b5 so I'll be
wanting to play a four to stop that as
soon as a six is played hmm that's a bit
awkward what's the big story behind h6
not so sure weakening for example if
there's ever an e5 push after I if I
capture if this pawn is ever capturing
this is super weakening the g6 square in
particular there's now a bit more of a
constraint on the f7 pawn with this last
move the light squares are a bit more
delicate a bit more soft now on the
black King side position a candidate
moves here my first my initial thoughts
are h3 rook e1 I had a thought of Bishop
f4 preparing Queen d2 that would be nice
to step the Queen up real quick and gain
a tempo now against h6 hmm h3 why would
I want to make them of h3 hmm h3 to stop
Bishop g4 and maybe a knight reposition
by way of Knight g4 to e5 um not sure
though actually you know I do want to
insert h3 and the primary reason I'm
assigning for playing this is to keep
him under control I'm not so sure I want
to allow this Bishop to exchange himself
off so quickly now Bishop d7 this is
prepping the b5 advance but it is in a
way getting in the way of let's say e5
and after the capture my knight
recaptures with tempo I wonder however
if I should spend an additional move
moving my Bishop from e2 to d3 I'm
probably not let me I think I want to
get Bishop f4 and yeah
f-for prep this advance and a lot more
oh you know another idea I'm I'm
recalling what this h6 move is to maybe
do some fancy night reposition to this
square out on how good it is I think
I've seen something like that but can't
be that great are we treating the night
like this it's not it's a somewhat
closed position but it can it can
definitely open up at any moment so
let's see candidate moves Bishop f4 rook
e1 hmm I like the idea of Bishop f4 and
Queen d2 you know I should shoot for
that right away let's go with it you
know another thing now that I keep
pressure on this there's not really any
worry of some epon push both my Queen
and Bishop are focused on that square so
my idea with this was to play a four
right away this is the first time b5 is
being threatened so let's stop that now
this and I could come back here Knight a
six in to be for this is a weakening
squeakin square okay so black is going
directly in for the b5 break clearly now
the move here to consider is a5 on a5
the V file can open up but I think I'll
have to
of a problem I like the position I have
right now I feel like it's under control
if 85 is in the B file can open up I'll
have to be watching over b2 but I could
one day have some setup for my bishop is
on c2 and my pawn is on b3 and
everything will be protected my Brook
will have play against the a pond in
some positions all in most cases it will
need to be watched over let's go with a
four or a five I'm expecting rook b8 and
another thing that might be a bit
uncomfortable for black is that it's
opposite my bishop so this starts to be
a bit more appealing having my bishop
opposite the rook but I think I might
want to know start some well I should
probably start with Queen d2 yeah and
let's definitely get that move in Queen
d2 developing with tempo against this
guy that cannot be bad King here and
this move starts to be all the more
appealing Bishop d3 because now in this
advance happens this pawn will be in a
pin so I'm thinking Bishop d3 not just
to be opposite the king but again for
this idea of one day kind of having the
bishop serve the role of defending my
pawn on b3
let's see Bishop d3 now b5 takes rook
takes and then I think I'm going to well
I could already think about 'if I've
even a five right now in this position I
think any tactics no not quite
let's go with hmm I'm not sure
oh no I want to see if I could get this
in because b2 could have a lot of
pressure on it very soon Bishop d3 b5
takes rook takes my ID was rook a to
Bishop c2 and then b3
however after Bishop d3 b5 takes rook
takes rook a to a queen b8 huh that's a
bit of a bug mm but the queen is
opposite my bishop let's see I'm just
trying to find a way to conveniently
defend the ensuing pressure on my beep
on that's what I'm devoting some time
here after the game I'll be checking
this game out with stockfish so we'll
see where all the mistakes are for both
sides if I do this Bishop d1 be 5 and
then b3 I'm tactically vulnerable to
this shop maybe
I
I should do let's play rookie 2 right
now after all that after all that you
spent 2 seconds and then play rook to a
- alright let's make it count let's make
it happen this was my bright idea to
play Bishop d1 so that I could play b3
and have it defended I think this is a
good way to coordinate the pieces and as
a follow-up move if I have time here
whoa really you know that something like
this happened before where I spent a ton
of time worrying about some sacrifice in
this square there's no way that could be
dangerous can it
I mean well actually what else is being
prepped here I find it hard to believe
that that could be good I just I don't
believe it
I don't believe it how about rook
should I really be concerned about some
sacrifice like that hmm I'll pawn push
that'll scare black maybe down to six
minutes living out for the increment
soon incoming King age to just to stop
any nonsense here and I like that let's
get my rook here how about that
you
yeah let's do this you know I had my
bishop here to watch out for Knight g4
if there's gonna be a sacrifice here I
was reluctant to play b3 because he
becomes a bit of a loose piece some
tricks here my queen would be tethered
to its defense so I'm not so fast with
me I'm expecting this this knot has to
be played but I mean what was the other
intention behind Queen here was it to
stack the stack these three pieces on
the B file I don't know that that's a
good idea because my bishop will be
conveniently defending this pawn unless
black goes in for some sacrifice to
pieces or I'm sorry giving up the
exchange and getting a pawn for it
that's a possibility because then c4
ceefor becomes a bit sensitive that's so
easy to defend although I'm really close
to just blowing this position open and I
believe I have the better position to
pieces the Knights on these good squares
here c3 and f3 he's a little bit awkward
on d2 but I'm really close to okay
that's what that's what black is going
in form I'm not going to make this move
just yet I think I should push through
with this advance here yeah and let me
interfere with this idea of maybe the
quick tripling up here I think I need to
go right in for that let's you know I
have all my pieces focused in the that
e5 square I should I should push through
I want I'm not just coming here to stare
at my own pond I want to maybe one day
look to get to the seventh rank in fact
that's already an idea some some capture
on d6 this is keep some this keeps this
rook a bit restricted so that's nice
what's our blacks decision going to be
if the night plays here he's kind of
sidelined and I hear Bishop back I'm
threatening g4 to trap tonight I'm
pretty sure that oh I'm pretty sure at
this point the computer would be saying
I stand better how much so not so sure
about that okay the Knights the knight
on c3 and this night I was on f6 they
were they were fighting for control over
these two squares how since he's gotten
I'm going to think about moving him ie4
is appealing in fact there might be some
tricks already with Knight g5 my knight
is any form I know for let's get this
night in here I think that's where he
belongs I have defense
vitu my queen and rook
this must be good how do you defend this
pond is the night kind of run in Reverse
here there really feels like there
should be some trick here I know the
computer would probably be lighting up
like crazy let's see the different
possibilities that I have available
maybe this push at some point to break
things up although that brings the rook
to life on the F file I could be
capturing this is the main threat and
additionally I'm keeping pressure on c5
so this pawn is ever capturing here okay
black is running in Reverse in order to
babysit this pawn and now very good
coordination so there should be
something here where is some knockout
how could I increase the pressure I
really feel like playing Knight g5 wow
it's like close to a perpetual even if
this rook wasn't defending this pawn how
could I get some more pieces working can
I add more pressure here not really
seeing that this bishop could be coming
out here at some point I don't know I
could be sneaky with like Bishop C to
getting my bishop here but Bishop f5
should be fine I think I'm gonna do this
though yeah let me do this I'm being I'm
being a bit sneaky
you
let's see I was just seeing a variation
I can't really voice with all my
thoughts right now but I'm seeing a
variation where it's three pieces for
the Queen what is where is something
good here how about how about I just
simply defend my palm do this no hun
push yeah I'm going to leave this
sitting
all right let's see if black cashes in
with some sacrifice here there it
definitely shouldn't be enough
compensation for that unbeli EV 5 I'm
gonna play Bishop here not to recapture
with the bishop but just to finally get
my bishop working what more could even
consider Knight g3 striking right back
at the bishop still it's still so many
pieces on the board this has to be good
with the space advantage night here my
first thought mm-hmm
let's do it yeah I can always go back
and yeah as a follow up Bishop c2 I
haven't forgotten
95 mph but uh we'll see okay Bishop here
let's get here pointing right at the
king so I have a lot of stuff lined up I
almost feel like black needs to do this
I mean what up this is like a sit and
wait strategy otherwise so now this is
actually a bit more appealing Night
Moves here in fact I could already think
about Knight h5 exploiting this pin so
there's a tricks right around the corner
if I could get rid of this dark square
Bishop probably bad stuff right around
the corner I imagine you have to get rid
of this pawn just so a knight could
finally make use of f6 but then I should
probably hop right to putting pressure
on c5 and that should collapse I mean
there's so many ways I could put
pressure on it okay five Queen e3 Bishop
e3 94 it's hard to imagine that this
pawn will live if this D pawn is no
longer around whoa
now that is a super super committal move
I could play this but I want to keep the
tension I don't want to do this and give
this square up so easily I think right
now I want to play h4 yeah I think I
definitely want to play h4 yeah let's go
for it you know
one of the reasons why was reluctant to
play h4 a bit sooner was because I'm gay
I gave up the G Foursquare to the bishop
but that's ruled out now that the pawn
is on f5 also if I didn't react
carefully here there might be some g5
push but there would already feel like
there's some sacrifice going on around
g5 feel like I'm just moment away from
breaking this down so I think I want to
take with the bishop mm-hmm being a
position to exchange yeah that can't be
bad
exchanging bishops there we go
could even think about recapturing with
my rook but I think my knight will
benefit the most
with the recapture so this is very very
very close to happening I don't know how
you can really stop it
playing age five and giving me the g5
square I can't really do that this has
enough support okay
just take this guy out what's this
Knight up to
take here and where is the killer shot
there's got to be something this is just
it's really really feels like it's being
held together by a thread
f5 has enough support now just take I
gotta be my gotta move a bit faster I
get my Queen immediately on this
diagonal or should I should I do this
first
yeah let me be a bit sneaky let's see
I think I could scoop that pun right up
let me let me go let me go hunt down
this c5 pyre I said it earlier and I
should really follow through with what I
said if the deep hunt isn't around he's
vulnerable I don't see how he could be
defended so let me stick to my guns here
let me follow through with my advice
pile up on this guy so the Queen's there
mmm
maybe the move orders wrong I probably
shouldn't overlook on with the rook
first okay well that's
well let's not quit how's that for
advice oh you're not quitting
there's night be7 to defend but how many
more night retreats are there gonna be
in this game I have this in mind maybe
93 to here or night d3 to f4 this is a
juicy square enough for you living off
of the increment before you know it
let's try not to let's say let's stay
afloat here let's try to stay above a
minute that middle will fly that minute
will fly very soon maybe I should have
thrown in the check I could set up some
sneaky discoveries but like on this move
94 there's night b7 mmm now though there
should be Queen c6 and our queen c3 with
some crazy tactics but will I have time
to calculate those tactics okay on this
move what I really play Knight e4 that
can't be right there's no way and I
could smash that pawn up and everything
the computer probably would have won by
now
let's run home yeah let's come all the
way home now on this move mm I can't be
so quick to play here now
on f4
I play here on pawn takes Knight then I
have there's gotta be something super
dangerous mmm that's so easy I mean
there's ways that you could interpose
here I don't know on f4 I think I'm
gonna go here
92 to c3
that's a nice square no I can't go to e2
it's same thing e to re-form blocking
this so on f4 maybe I go to f1 okay
they're not doing that okay I think I
really want to get here right now mm-hmm
let me let me get this rook working
actually right here my piece is working
and well centralised on pawn push I'm
gonna take their on pawn takes I'm
taking with the pond so I have the C 4
square well this will be a nice post I
gained a tempo even against the rook I
do have this check in mind I have
pressure on h6 I still have this idea of
pressing here okay
um I feel like black is slithering out
of this don't like it am I not
structure down though pond push is now
the moment for it let me let me force
black to be a bit uncomfortable let's
let's be opposite the King the King's
gonna have to move and now maybe
something like this so I could capture
on this square with tempo or with check
so much for that talked about staying
above in one minute okay h5 g5 and then
chop here chop there cuz the Knights
blocking at five I think this is a bit
soft now whoa okay there should be no
fear why am i welling just take care
it's Knights in a pin might as well view
it already isn't a pin there's even
better stuff I think knight c6 and then
rook here and they should really be
crumbling what about rook here let's
let's play fast the Knights in a pin so
d5 cannot be taken good think about
pushing I can think about playing rook
here I'm gonna play this next because
these are the only two pieces that are
really doing anything just yet I can
maybe even sacrifice here there must be
a sacrifice but I'm gonna go about it in
a way where I don't sacrifice any
material and I want to just break down
on f5 I want to be able to attack for
free less than 20 I want to attack in a
way where I'm not investing any material
could have also played here but this is
this is definitely collapsing against
against the black King let's see I'm not
sure take NGC
if they take here I'm taking here if
they push and I can play here and pile
up on this guy there's checks ok night
there um I should just take right away
yeah let's take right away f5 is now in
big big trouble I also have this move
Knight here that's sneaky Knight
okay where is it good spot for my queen
oh my goodness I almost lost some time
I'm forgetting there's a pawn fork here
why did I take the Queen off of the
diagonal ah this is not good I almost
lost on time again this is now how I
wanted it to happen oh man I'm hitting
the night where is the way to finish
this off I can't believe I allowed the
Queen's come off the board oh man I want
to take on f5 or c5 take here even know
what the material count is that's check
take
this pond live this guy's defended I
have night check here isn't that me this
is a mate threat hmm they might miss it
if they move really fast night here's a
killer if this night moves I could take
care 7 seconds this is like an eternity
compared to what I had before her oh my
goodness night year could take on c5 if
not here to defend this check um I could
do a pawn push Knight here and then this
this should be good I'm night here a
night at 5:00 I'm going to take this
pawn I'm up upon here so be fine with
trading let's kick him out of here
he defended to me oh that was a sneaky
move very sneaky move I want to get rid
of the knight okay this should be much
easier to play without that silly Knight
around that guy is so scary that Knight
is so scary I just take this pawn let's
keep it very very simple let's get back
here with this check I'm on this guy how
could I keep it really simple
I'd like to just have the
looks around if he works himself into a
pin I'm gonna play Bishop here let's
kick that rook where's the killer move
where is it
ah sure what that's doing exactly why
did I move my knight why did I move my
knight no time I should have I should
have played like Bishop here to attack
the knight let's try it again
I think it was my pawn although I could
do this the Knights gonna move here I'm
playing this is super super super sloppy
put him in a pin this probably could be
taken but man this is terrible terrible
terrible technique awful this game
should not be continuing just gonna play
here to make it a little bit easier
simplify it a bit more Oh got a re win
this game it's not easy either
not at all have this square covered I
have the wrong color Bishop as well when
it comes for the comes time for the rook
pawn that's why I played my rook there
for this well actually
what am I talking about wrong color Ron
collar bishop I don't even have an H
pawn so that's not really much of a
factor oh I had this move no I was in
check ah this is winning now oh man
finally that was sloppiness sloppiness
this should have been converted a long
long time ago and it wasn't okay let's
make sure that Knight doesn't kill me
I just want to get rid of the knight
watch out for any
enos give this rook check and then
another rook check if the rook is
attacked so I guess they're gonna play
this out a little bit throw this in here
just to gain some time here no matter
what
okay they should be finishing up soon
and I have plenty of time
oh that would have really really stung
there's no steel matrix that would have
really really stung if I lost on time
there really what of okay let's push
this guy push that pass pawn keep
pushing and watch out for any sneaky
stalemates I guess we're gonna play this
one out to me I'm really interested to
see where I could have put the final
touches on this game should not still be
going here okay they resigned all right
I'm gonna go into I'm gonna go into
analysis mode and I will see what
stockfish has to say about this one I
officially loaded it up here let's see
what stock fish has to say about this
game early stage nothing exciting I'll
let you guys know when there's a big
shift with the evaluation oh this was
the first moment this age six Rose is
there anything crazy I could be doing
against that now Peters suggesting age
three I did play age three okay Bishop
d7 computer wants to play a three mmm I
really see a reason to play a three
because my main intention is playing a
four so I'm just I would just be losing
a tempo okay maybe maybe there's some
idea with a three rupee one and as soon
as the knight moves maybe we strike here
but seems like there would be as some
more prep work needed with defending my
knight on c3
of f/4 computer calls up for g5 right
here yeah that's computer chess
evaluation is close to +1 here and it
likes this idea of the night maybe
coming back into B for I don't know how
big of an issue that would be I'd be
following up with rookie one and still
pushing through with the e5 I went with
a six and computer wants to go they
should h2 yeah I don't see pulling that
I like this move so at least gain a
tempo and if the bishop then wants to go
back we could go back Peter wants to
play e5 here that's what I eventually
did but the B file opened up Queen d2
wants to play e5 here but I wanted to
take some prep work here anticipating
the pressure against the beep on got
that in there anything wrong with this
little retreat I'm always a bit hesitant
making these retreating moves the
computer usually has something to say
about it something bad to say about a
retreating move but not the case here
clean their rope here and now it's
really going bonkers it's saying about
plus two and a half starting with e5
figured it would be an advantage I
didn't know about two and a half though
Bishop c2 it's calling for Bishop c2 but
this is fine as well
Bishop c2 I'll point out that out
earlier three pieces for them right here
in fact Bishop c2 this is what I was uh
talking about there's this variation
where you could have the captures but
then after Knight f6 he takes there's
Bishop takes I miss I had a blind spot
here I was thinking was three minor
pieces for the Queen for some reason I
was thinking that the rook would be able
to come down here and take the bishop
but I didn't I didn't see that after
this capture this file is closed
anyhow my opponent wouldn't have fallen
for that but it was an ideas to still
play here in other words instead of
investing some time with b3 b3 Bishop
there
it likes Knight g3 I likes Bishop c2 and
that wants to take on some but this is
this is really still in a huge advantage
it's right around two and a half the
whole way yeah I wasn't really too too
big a fan of this move it likes 95 here
but where could I have finished better
right around here there's gotta be
something C takes Knight there h5 wants
to play h5 right away okay we're in the
realm of like +4 territory so I think
that does slip away
Oh Knight h5 right now
what's the trick with 9h five what did I
do here I ran away with my queen this is
where I almost lost ten time oh my
goodness without if stung Knight h5 King
takes pawn bishop takes f5 I'm not going
to be calculating that with no time on
the clock King takes there it's a mate
in seven there and then 95 yeah I'm not
I'm not going to be able to do this with
so few few seconds on the clock but this
is this is a killer shot Knight h5 again
should play that move much sooner and
right around here this is as soon as the
Queen's are off I knew it was changing
the evaluation and it definitely is it's
only giving me like a point seven
advantage ouch was ever losing at any
point now now it's back up to a
significant amount like +3 and beyond
what better resistance once I got to
this point on the black side after rook
takes night before was being called for
attacking this guy and then the
variation it's sighting is Knight takes
King takes walking into a discovered
trick discovered check like take c2
Knight takes and yeah it's still fight
man just fortunate I guess that it
didn't lose on time and I don't think
that anything is really changing much
around here actually maybe it is yeah
it's only about a pawn advantage here
less than a pawn and they missed that
little check here I think I got the
feeling and it's easy to do sometimes an
opponent will play like they have they
had plenty of time or compared to me
they had plenty of time but trying to
play faster when it's not really needed
and then this is of course a winning
endgame but interesting game typical of
when you have this trio of pawns to
eventually obtain some space advantage
and black never really got a successful
pawn break in I guess the
the main the main thing that I'm
thinking about with this any pressure on
the B file was kind of non-existent and
I was able to push through in the center
successfully okay
anyhow I've spoken long enough this
video has gone on long enough
as always I hope you got something on
this video and I'll catch you in the
next one take care bye
you